la première ministre danoise qui
trinquent en l'honneur d'un nouvel
espoir
le danemark sur le point de retrouver
une vie normale
nous rentrons bientôt à la maison après
une bonne et longue journée heureux que
nous ayons un plan à long terme pour
rouvrir le danemark métaux frédéric
scène qui se félicite d'un accord trouvé
lundi avec différentes parties
politiques du parlement
sociaux-démocrates gauche radicaux ou
encore conservateur un accord cadre
un document de sept pages et un objectif
premier
affiché à quelques exceptions près la
société danoise doit pouvoir être
ouverte lorsque toute personne âgée de
plus de 50 ans aura été vaccinées une
réouverture souple et responsable d'ici
fin mai prévient le gouvernement à
l'image des collégiens et lycéens
autorisé à revenir en classe une semaine
sur deux à partir du 6 avril
le danemark optimiste et avant gardiste
dans les prochaines semaines 1 parce qu
au renard sera obligatoire pour se
rendre chez le coiffeur ou au restaurant
le corona passe indiquera si le citoyen
été vaccinées s'il a vaincu une
infection ou s'il a été testés négatifs
dans les 72 heures à la fois par pcr et
par test antigénique les enfants de
moins de 15 ans seront exemptés apas
numérique ou papier
en attendant une ouverture de la
vaccination aux 5,8 millions de da nau a
prévu à la fin du mois aujourd'hui plus
de 5 % de la population a été totalement
vacciner plus de 10% a reçu une première
dose
le gouvernement se montre prudent le
calendrier s'annonce chargé ces deux
prochains mois
tous les secteurs sont concernés avec
pour simple règle le respect de la
distanciation social le port du masque
ou encore décourager le principe de
flânerie ou l'attroupement sur les bancs
des informations complémentaires sont
attendus mi avril concernant les
événements à forte affluence
quand les festivals de musique et les
matches de football professionnels
les danois doivent accueillir certaines
rencontres de l'euro de foot
fin juin